the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
hill plan show i'm so excited for today
because i have a guest that i know is
going to provide so much value and
you're absolutely going to love now
before i bring on my guest i do want to
let you know as always that this podcast
is sponsored by bitmex so bitmex is
actually the og crypto derivatives
exchange and now has a spot exchange for
you to buy and sell your bitcoin and
many different cryptocurrencies
especially in this bear market you do
need a name that you can trust and
bitmex sets the standard in reliability
performance and transparency and has
proven itself through multiple market
cycles and has stood the test of time
which is very important right now bimx
is actually celebrating the start of
bitmex spot with one million dollars in
prizes to give away so if you do want to
enter all you need to do is trade the
equivalent of 250
so you can grab some bitcoin for 250
during the crash you can actually enter
up to 25 times and one lucky winner will
even receive 500 000 in bitcoin so to
sign up i'm gonna leave um all the links
in the description for you below so if
you do want to grab some bitcoin during
the dip then now is a really great time
now before i bring on my guests i do
want to let you know um that
on this podcast as always we do bring
you the highest quality content we speak
to some incredible guests so please
don't forget to hit the like button and
subscribe so you never miss a video so
who is coming today
well joining me on the show today is a
man that was previously the lead crisis
negotiator for new york city's fbi
division he's the fbi lead international
kidnapping negotiator he teaches
business negotiating at universities
across the state he's the founder and
the ceo of the black swan group and
author of never split the difference if
you don't know already it is of course
chris voss chris welcome to the show how
are you i am happy to be here thank you
very much thanks for having me on
yes such a pleasure i'm so fascinated by
your work um i've never spoken to a
hostage negotiator before in my life um
oh it's probably a good thing right
absolutely it is a good thing um so i'm
really fascinated i'm also fascinated by
how um transferable the skills
apparently are um so we're gonna get
into all of that um but before we do i'm
really curious what does it mean to be
the lead fbi hostage negotiator can you
explain what that even looks like well i
was uh i was a lead international
kidnapping negotiator so you know there
was sort of a cadre of us having a
variety of different responsibilities
and what that meant for me was any
american that got kidnapped anywhere in
the world
it was my job to come up with a
negotiation strategy
that would get them out safely and then
ideally in a way that we'd bring the bad
guys to justice to
how did you get into that it's so niche
yeah you know one left turn after
another i mean i i pursued stuff that i
found really interesting and intriguing
and also the if the people around it
you know were kind of like my tribe my
my people uh shared my core values
and so you know a purposeful mission
with people that i enjoyed working with
and and my kind of person is
figured out like in my company
we describe it as a midwestern united
states work ethic you know roll up your
sleeves blue collar uh help the team and
you know have fun at the same time you
know be very good natured about it and
those people
were around the job that i thought would
be enjoyable it worked out for me
so i'm really curious to understand what
it was like um being a hostage or
kidnapping negotiator what did you learn
about human behavior
yeah slowly slowly but surely um
human behavior is pretty much the same
and i've really learned that more since
i left the fbi like when i got into
hostage negotiation
they first said look you don't have any
background any qualifications so the
only way you could do this is to
volunteer on a crisis hotline
so i did you know it was we didn't know
it at the time but it was just the most
learning emotional intelligence
with people theoretically under stress
but then i learned and i thought you
know this this stuff's so good it's just
got to apply in everyday life i mean
empathy why should you only apply
empathy to somebody who's under stress
so i started applying it in everyday
life and
then it became a big part of even kidnap
bargaining bail knuckle brass tax
bargaining
uh people on the other side are pretty
much driven by
you know what does this mean to them as
a human being
you know how was their identity involved
and what kind of loss
have they suffered that's driven them to
this horrific behavior
and then you know that those are the
rules of hostage negotiation and then
about 2002
daniel
kahneman uh won the nobel prize in
behavioral economics they're saying like
yeah loss pretty much drives everybody
in their thinking it's not the only
thing but it's just the biggest driver
that's when i really began to learn that
the stuff we learned in hostage
negotiations just human behavior
so loss and empathy um are two important
things but
um can you talk to me about the mental
strategy that you go through when you're
trying to
negotiate out of a situation obviously a
hostage situation but any situation
which seems like an impossible situation
well um if you if
everything you deal with seems
impossible then that isn't that hard you
know like i used to say everything we
were doing was a long shot
well if my chances are slim or none
i'll take slim
and you just get used to slim it doesn't
rattle you and then you begin to realize
that you can start making subtle
differences
and few things really are long shots few
are i'm some are you got to know learn
the difference
but if you just get into it
if you're not afraid of working without
a net
or it being a long shot then this stuff
comes to you i think the biggest thing
that i learned i repeated this phrase a
lot
i learned it from my boss best chance of
success
well best chance of success by
definition
means that not everything is going to
work out
and if you accept that and that you just
want to do the thing that's most likely
to work out then you get a lot better
what about the pressure in that
situation because um because we're gonna
talk a bit about the business side of
things and the skills being transferable
but
this is serious this isn't just losing
you know some money this is like losing
a human being so how do you handle the
pressure you know you're the lead guy
you know yeah yeah you get used to it a
little at a time
really can you
you know it's kind of it's kind of the
boiling frog analogy you know there's a
metaphor of
you can't drop a frog in the boiling
water but you can put them in room
temperature water and slowly raise the
temperature and they can they can adapt
and adjust
you know
in the training
they hit us right between the eyes early
on in the training
with a scenario that went bad
unexpectedly
and it was very purposeful
to be like let's not kid ourselves you
know these are dangerous situations
and if you accept that early on and you
should
then you're like all right so i got to
be prepared to get into something
that's kind of heavy
and if you talk about it theoretically
when it really happens it's still really
hard to deal with
but you were warned
and people are incredibly resilient
with warning it's people getting caught
off guard by stressors that are the real
problem
so you know i paid attention to the
warnings people told me stuff and
i listened you know i i i believe what
they said
and so that you know that's just kind of
how you deal with it you think about it
theoretically which prepares for you to
deal with it in reality
so sort of preparing for the worst case
scenario and any things that could pop
up yeah being aware
that it could happen
um
among you know i read a lot of other
stuff one of the things i like reading a
lot eric barker
writes a blog called barking up their
own tree i think eric's a brilliant guy
i read his stuff you know very layman
oriented
he wrote a long time ago
about preparation for tragedy use the
samurai analogy
he said you know the samurai dealt with
death because they thought about it as a
possibility they just simply accepted
it was one of a number of possible
outcomes so they were warned and it was
not the outcome but a possible outcome
and they got and they became they lost
their fear of death just because they
thought it through
i'm coaching a kidnapping a number of
years ago
and uh the brother who saved his his
brother's life i'm coaching the brother
of the victim
you know he was i mean he took our
coaching he was very coachable he
listened so well he even made some stuff
up on his own within what we taught him
and afterwards i said i said man like
you you are coachable you were you you
were phenomenal i said how how is that
that you were this good
and he said you know i just
i realized early on that my brother
could die
and that it was a possible outcome
and i thought you know all right so i'm
aware of this let me engage and do my
best and i really thought that that was
similar to the samurai analogy you're
not
you you're not um caught up that it's
the only outcome
but it's an outcome
and when you see that as a one of a
number of possibilities you actually
you're much more flexible
that makes a lot of sense um do you
remember your most challenging hostage
negotiation
well you know the
it would have been probably one of two i
mean
the second case of working in the
philippines the burnham superior case
came right on the heels of a case
previously that went magnificently we
got the hostage out the hostage walked
away no ransom was paid
and the bad guys organization was left
pretty much in the shambles as a result
another another kidnapping kicked off
just about
a month after that one with a different
branch
of the franchise if you will you know
every every everything's an organization
an organizational structure is the same
and
terrorist groups or organizations and
they get different franchises you know
different branches of the franchise
and that one was a mess from beginning
to end the biggest problem was
coordinating the government entities
because we've been so successful
previously
they felt less under crisis
so you know they
they didn't collaborate as well as we
should have across the board and it was
between the u.s government
a little bit of disorganization and the
philippine government this organization
the crisis within the crisis was much
worse than
than dealing with the bad guys was and
that and that thing uh
you know
it had a number of melancholy outcomes a
number of people unfortunately didn't
make it through
in terms of everything that you learned
um you're now obviously teaching
business negotiation um which is
fascinating so how and why are the
skills transferable
yeah because you know human decision
making under stress
still follows kind of the same rules
and there's a phrase your biggest
problem is your biggest problem
like in the business world people are
negotiating
because their livelihoods depend on it
and so they have a tendency to get as
emotionally invested as it would
otherwise because it's the most
stressful thing in their life at the
time
and human decision making is really
what's the loss i mean it's it really
interesting that
people calculate what they're losing
and figure that out before they think
about what they're gaining i remember
hearing a friend of mine and i don't
know the source of the statistic but
she really knows business and she said
seventy percent of buy decisions
are made to avoid a loss
instead of accomplishing a gain
that's interesting and that ratio is
about right because there's a two to one
impact pretty much of loss over gain
and when you can grasp that and you
instead of selling
you know if somebody doesn't agree with
you you've got to understand they see it
lost differently than what you see
and you need to sort of get in their
head by invitation you know with
tactical empathy
actual empathy not pretend empathy
and and tell them what you think their
perspective is
and let them correct you
and then you got an opportunity since
you're in there you have a relationship
a rapport by invitation
you might be able to get them to change
your mind so i want to get into that can
you give me an example what do you mean
by empathy because i've heard you talk a
lot about getting um people to say
that's right and we call it tr um so say
you're in um like a say you're trying to
negotiate a salary you know this is
relevant right now inflation is soaring
salaries aren't reflecting that so
somebody wants to approach their boss um
and you know you're talking about
empathy and you're talking about um you
know getting them to say that's right
what does that actually look like
all right so from your boss's
perspective
what does your boss want
somebody's a team player
someone who follows direction someone
who gets their ego out of the way
that's what any boss wants yeah you
start by saying that
look you're looking for a team player
you're looking for somebody that's not a
diva you're looking for somebody that
has integrity
and guidance and is trustworthy
i mean because they want to know that
you're aware of that
and they no one knows
that you're aware
until you say it out loud it's one of
the real big misunderstand two biggest
misunderstandings about empathy number
one empathy acquaints his sympathy it
does not
a friend of mine stephen cutler said
empathy is about the transmission of
information
compassion is the reaction to the
transmission
so you have complete empathy with
someone
and it's a precursor for compassion
but it doesn't necessarily need
compassion to have empathy it's not
agreement it's not a like liking it's
not sympathy
it's being fully aware of the other
side's perspective so problem one is
people equate it to sympathy and it's
not
people equate it to compassion agreement
it's not it's none of those things it's
very neutral
so the problem two is
you gotta tell them what you think their
perspective is
because they you don't know that you've
got it right until you check with them
okay and give them the opportunity to
correct you
just seeing it from their point of view
is step one
and it's inadequate alone
you got to feedback what you're looking
for if you feed back to the boss the
very things
that i said before you know you're
looking for somebody that's a team
player you're looking for somebody that
takes direction well and what's going to
happen when you
give them what you think their
perspective is
whatever they you've left out
they're going to add in which is
critical information like if the boss is
really looking for somebody
who works well alone
then when you say you're looking for a
team player the boss is going to say
yeah but i need you to work well alone
like that's great information that's
exactly what you were looking for yeah
what you've left out that's important to
them
they will add in
so then you repeat it back to him
and that's when you're driving for
that's right
now what happens
when you get the magic that's right
when people feel
fully understood
and it's the stuff we just learned the
last couple years neuroscience what's
the neuroscience
when you feel completely understood
you get ahead of two of your own neural
chemicals
that work wonders
oxytocin which is the bonding drug
so when you feel understood you feel
bonded to me we got rapport
you're giving me influence
it's more than even like me i mean you
like me and you feel bonded to me
now another crazy thing that i ran
across recently on oxytocin
it inclines you to tell the truth
so not only do you like me
you feel bonded to me
you're going to be more honest with me
oh that sounds like a good business
relationship
now the kicker
you also get a hit of serotonin
serotonin is a drug of satisfaction
which means
suddenly you're less greedy
and you're more giving
so
in a negotiation you're bonded to me you
like me you're more likely to be honest
and you want to take less you want to
grab less in the deal you be satisfied
which is the interaction
i have to give up less i mean what what
more do you want for me from the mere
act of making somebody feel understood
so this is the boss the boss feels this
way when you say right the boss or any
human being i mean this applies to any
human being but yes it applies to the
boss
there's some other things you're going
to want to make sure of with the boss
but they all pretty much revolve around
whether or not you're a team player
instead of a diva
who's only selfish like you know i need
to get paid more
that's selfish
yeah
i want to make the team better
oh that's maybe that's not so selfish
you know that benefits everybody
what behaviors are you going to engage
in
to make the team better that's going to
make life better for the boss
bosses employee employers
whether we as employees like it or not
[Music]
essentially see employees mostly as
selfish
when do you walk into the boss's office
when you want something
what do you talk about in
a job negotiation
stuff for you
what do you talk about in the annual
review
stuff for you
i mean look at all the feedback that
employers get
about employees being selfish
when you start talk coming in and ask a
different question the magic question is
that every employee should ask in their
job interviews and in every annual
performance review
how can i be guaranteed
to be involved in projects
that are critical
to the strategic future of this
organization
what a question
i was doing a keynote speech
i don't know eight ten months ago
ceo of a sales organization
and all his top sales people
and we did the q a and one of the sales
people said
how do we negotiate with our boss
what do we say you know and you could
just feel the tension in the air
like because the boss is there listening
to this
what's he going to say without making
the boss mad because the boss's pain has
got to be here yeah what you're going to
say is going to help us
and i said this is what you ask how can
i be guaranteed to involve be involved
in projects critical to the strategic
future of the organization
i said you asked that
and you are going to get better projects
you're going to get the boss's attention
because the boss sees you as a team
player
and you're either going to deliver more
value and get paid more
or you're going to deliver more value
and shop
your resume because of the great things
you did and go elsewhere if the boss
won't pay you
and as soon as i finished that
explanation the ceo said i wish everyone
in my organization would ask me this
yeah i'm sure
and it's about you getting paid more
and having a better resume
so that life is your life has more
accomplishment and achievement in it
yeah that makes a lot of sense i think a
lot of people definitely approach um
jobs you know um based on what can you
do for me you know what what's the pay
is there medical insurance that you know
it always lacks that you know how can i
offer value
um but outside of um the negotiation
between a boss and employee um you know
you talk about negotiations in general
um and there's something about uh yes or
no questions can you explain that to me
i mean a black swan group is out of the
yes business if you're learning a black
swan method
we are out of the yes business we used
to say yes there's nothing without how
and now we say yes is nothing and how is
everything what does that mean now first
of all what's the problem with yes
the first problem is you think yes is
success
nine out of ten yeses are counterfeit
so if you think yes a success
you got to counter for yes
and you're you're in a completely
different
ballpark than the other person
because they gave you a counter for yes
because they want you to keep talking
they gave you counterfeit yes to to see
where you're going but they're leery of
where the traps are and there's always
there's always a hook buried in yes do
you want to make more money do you want
to live in a bigger house
do you want to travel the world stay in
five-star hotels for free do you want
free hotel upgrades
you know those are all yes so any
questions and if i was trying to get you
to buy my book because you can learn all
those things from never split the
difference
but if i were to do it like that you'd
be like there's a hook coming here this
guy's trying to sell me something you
know he's got an agenda so i'll say yes
because because i want to know where
it's going
now people that are engaged in this yes
nonsense
think they're on the right track they it
doesn't even occur to them that they're
getting a fake yes
you know classic example in sales
or in business is if you're being played
against another competitor and you don't
even know it you're the fool in the game
you're the rabbit you're driving down
the price
they're looking you to because they want
to kick the tires or free consulting or
competing bit
the question that some sales books tell
people to say is are we the vendor of
choice
there's no way they're not going to say
yes to that they'd be stupid if they
didn't yeah
when in mo 8 out of 10 times you're not
yeah i mean if you if you don't know who
the fool in the game is it's probably
you
if you're the favorite you know you're
the favorite so if you're if you don't
know you're the favorite
and you're wondering who the fool is
who's being played it's you
well you ask them a yes or another
question
they're going to lie to you they're
going to give you the counterfeit yes
so yes this isn't success which means
that no by definition is not failure
and probably one of the most critical
turning points
in every negotiator's career
is understanding what yes and no really
is
okay
yes is at best
is aspiration only that's why it's
nothing without have
and more than likely it's counterfeit
no on the other hand when somebody says
it
not when you hear it but what happens
when somebody says it
they feel safe
they feel protected
they're no longer worried about
a hook
even something as little as
nobody in my company ever says have you
got a few minutes to talk nobody that
we've trained
and who understood ever says have you
got a few minutes to talk the question
is always is now a bad time
is now a bad time okay so what are they
going to say no you got you're going to
get one of three responses they're going
to say no no no no go ahead
because they felt safe and in control
in that you gave them because you gave
them uh an opening to leave
yeah you gave you preserved their
autonomy
um
you know for a sort of a philosophical
metaphysical
uh description of it yeah you know
people you know people die to preserve
their economy their freedom
yeah that's a human nature aspect
now understanding what you say after
that you know
no oriented question buys you about 30
seconds 30 to 60 seconds what you follow
it up with is very important
but we say it's now a bad time to talk
and no it's never a bad time or they
might come back with
yeah it is a bad time i'm gonna zoom
call right now i'll call you in 30
minutes that's exactly what i got
on that no oriented question and
somebody had texted the other day
because i need their attention
like i could have rang this guy up
he was and he would have answered the
phone while he was on a zoom call
and i might have thought since he
answered i could talk to him without
really realizing he's on a zoom call
he's going to be completely distracted
between the two
i don't need divided attention
i do need to know when i can talk to
them
and if they if there's an opportunity in
the near term for them to talk to you
they'll tell you when
which now means they've agreed to the
conversation and when it's going to
happen and again you've got their full
attention and they feel their autonomy
is safe
now the third tricky answer is science
like one in
a hundred times
is now bad time to talk is met with
silence it's probably overall the
highest percentage success
of any of the black swan skills
you get silence the answer is yes
and there's stuff going on here now i'm
struggling i'm drowning
i don't want to talk to you because
either i've got bad news or i've got no
news
that's actually good information to know
that the other person probably feels
backed into a corner at the moment
you shoot out the text message is now
bad time to talk and you get silence
over an hour
shoot the empathy
is
you're probably under a lot of pressure
right now
you probably feel really backed into a
corner right now
now they still may not respond but
that's not the point the point is what
do they feel when they read that
they feel understood they feel
appreciated you're starting to kick in
those neurochemicals that i was talking
about before
that play to your advantage long term
so the whole yes no dynamic from the
black swan method is completely
different than you'll learn anywhere
else
and i can tell you if you can just
simply master that difference
it's a it's a low estimate
that all your success rates are going to
improve by 23
you've just given yourself
a 23
increase in pay
what's the just to clarify what's the
difference i'm saying between saying is
now a bad time versus is now a good time
it's now a good time to in in the corner
that's like a
that's a yes response question well what
goes through somebody's mind is is now a
good time to talk or have you got a few
minutes to talk
here's what goes through their mind
depends upon what you want to talk about
mm-hmm yeah i might not want to talk
about what you want to talk about i like
talking to you i just don't want to talk
about what you want to talk about um
how long is a few minutes
you know there's a whole separate
problem with a few minutes
it's usually 45
yes like nobody knows how long a few
minutes is like i can't commit to that i
don't know how long a few minutes are
it's now a bad time to talk no it's not
a bad time but i got 15 minutes is the
answer
you just cleared up the whole time frame
or no it's not a bad time but i'm on a
zoom call i can talk to you in 30
minutes
the real issue is how do they respond to
the question how much gets cleared up
right away
and the mere act of saying no
makes people feel safe
so there's less than anxiety in their
response and they can think through it
much more clearly
yeah i can relate to that i do that a
lot i say no
to bring back my autonomy like if i'm
uncomfortable i'm just like okay now
it's just a clear no and then we can go
from there like we can work from i've
said no now i don't know anyone anything
and now we can build um so
exactly because you you you protected
yourself now i can talk without any
implied commitment
yeah and the implied commitment is a
real problem with people that are into
this yes nonsense
they call it momentum selling or the yes
momentum when they teach it they say
each yes is actually a tied down
nobody likes to get tied down
nobody likes to get cornered nobody
likes implied commitments and that's
what the whole yes momentum nonsense is
all about you know you're trying to tie
somebody down you're trying to hook them
you're trying to trap and we're trying
to corner them so they're implied
commitments when the other person is not
prepared and doesn't like implied
commitments yeah it makes so much sense
how do you then deal with getting a no
um i watched a video actually of yours
um i can't remember i think maybe it was
a google talk maybe um and the girl was
saying she asked for some chairs and
they said no and then she got the chairs
in the end so how do you negotiate when
somebody originally just says no whether
it's you know i can't increase your
salary or um no we can't pay you that
much or just a simple no we you know
this won't work for us well and bringing
it back back around the salary is a
really good idea because
salary only pays your bills it doesn't
make your career
right like most people assume like you
pay me a lot of money i'm going to be a
superstar my career is going to be made
because i get paid a lot and i'm
incentivized and i'll do fantastic
and that is not the case i mean people
say that and simultaneously
all human beings say money's not a
motivator
so
salary doesn't make your career
salary pays your bills yes now a low
salary can break the deal
but you're not going to be guaranteed to
become successful based on your salary
you need to know the lay of the land you
need to know what they think it takes to
become successful you need to know what
are their expectations of view
which are all
non-salary terms
about success
that is not that you need to know for
your job
like are they expecting you
to be completely autonomous do they
really need somebody who's completely
autonomous
to be completely autonomous and a team
player
it's kind of tricky how do you work that
out is that what they're looking for
what do they mean by those terms like in
my company one of our core values
we used to say being a team player
there isn't anybody on earth that's
going to say i'm not a team player yeah
the real difference is do they want to
be a member of the team
or do they want to lead the team
yes do they want to support the team or
do they want the team to support them do
they want to join your team do you they
want you to join their team
i mean i i turned down a retired fbi
hostage negotiator because he wanted his
own organization he was willing to work
with us
and i finally said to him like look
the fact of the matter is you want us to
join your team you don't want to join
our team
and he went dead silent the fit wasn't
there
so we no longer say team players we say
team first
now that's different
now you may not have heard that properly
but if we run into problems later on we
very clearly say that i said that up
front
we say things like
inaction is a bigger sin than a mistake
and the biggest sin of all is to not to
learn from your mistakes
you know what does that mean we need you
to take action
i don't expect it to be perfect
when you make a mistake
you can probably make it two maybe three
times
you make it seven eight nine times
you're not learning
you know in my company for us to push
the envelope for us to get better for us
to stay ahead of everybody which we are
we got to make mistakes
and learn from them that's one of the
reasons why our method continues to get
better than anybody else's because we're
continually we walk our own talk
you know we negotiate for a living we
negotiate for our for our
for our bread if you will you know for
our food
and we need to have long-term
relationships because
if you if you cheat people in
negotiations if you fail to deliver
you don't get customers anymore
so we walk our talk on a regular basis
and we understand what it takes
and what we ask of people to be a
successful member of our team as an
employee you got to figure that out
otherwise it's a bad fit
but what happens when you're speaking
with somebody and they say to you um you
know
this is how much we'll pay you and you
know that that's not gonna work you know
it's a no so how do you how do you
navigate and know though
well um
first of all you know what else is going
with the job
is the real issue can you build your
career here like
take the most successful business person
that anybody could think of i don't know
who you think of i'm thinking of either
warren buffett or oprah winfrey two of
my favorites okay
like i'd go be warren buffett's personal
assistant for 15 an hour
and i make a lot more than that now
but i would
get rid of all of it for a year
to be his assistant and learn from him
well oprah winfrey same thing i you know
i'd go be her personal assistant for a
year for 15 an hour
so what are you getting with the job is
the salary
really what's breaking the deal
or the future prospects
which break in the deal
a friend of mine is ahead of an
international bank
he's famous for
paying people
at market or slightly less
and retaining them for longer than
anybody else in this industry
now how is he not paying people high
and simultaneously retaining them
his focus is on helping them build their
lives
and not just their professional lives
like their personal lives like if he's
if he when he says to you what do you
really want out of life
you know what do you really really want
and if they say
yeah i want to build lower cabins in the
woods
he said he'll say all right so how do we
integrate you learning about that
into your job that's nice how long is it
going to take you to learn about that
well i got to study log cabin building
for four years
all right so
let's figure out a way to integrate that
into your job here
so that you can be successful at work
and still fulfill your life's ambition
that's powerful what's he but he's just
now got that person for four years
and then i quit in a year
or two
well they're not shopping in three you
know what's a typical turnover in many
jobs a long time ago used to be the two
three years max and you started shopping
employ employers because you need to go
someplace else because they're not
giving you a raise and your life isn't
moving forward
that's how he retains people it's what
goes with the job he actually cares
about you
your employer employee relationship
is a marriage
and if your counterpart doesn't care
about you growing and blossoming as a
human being personally and professional
it's a wrong job find somebody who does
want that for you
that's really powerful um
when it comes to negotiation there's
obviously this sort of
fair value of exchange which you have to
figure out so how do you um navigate
understanding you know whether you're
asking for too much
um or whether they're asking for too
much from you like how do you understand
whether this is fair or for both parties
well yeah fair is like beauty it's in
the eye of the beholder very true and
you know and there's also some
you know what if they can't afford to
pay you top dollar
but the experience of being there is
going to be like no other spare
experience
like what you know what if you're you're
in a startup operation it still has to
go several uh funding rounds
and you know nothing about funding like
i i've never i've never solicited
funding i was in a conversation last
night with a guy who's getting ready to
raise his plan is to raise eight million
dollars and building out the business
plan and what does that look like in
building a business case and i thought
wow
i don't know anything about that stuff
like if i came to work for you now and i
learned all that in the coming year
if i knew how to raise eight million
dollars if i knew how to build a
business case i'd go out and start my
own business or you it might qualify me
to be a strategic thinker in somebody
else's business that needs to do the
same thing
what would i work for
i you know i i would to gain that kind
of knowledge on building businesses and
finances
i'd work for less doing that
so really what's it going to do for your
life
you do want to find out whether or not
they're low balling you
or whether or not they just don't have
the ability to pay
now there's questions like that
what's their process the process in
advance is
they got a range for your salary
they got latitude within that range
and they have the ability if you can
make the case to go outside that range
so how do you how do you articulate with
that
you say well you probably got a range
from my salary
you probably dropped me into a couple of
different job descriptions
and you're trying to see exactly where i
fit
that's the most successful both for the
company and for you because you're going
to be held accountable for what kind of
a deal that we cut
so
you start asking for people about ranges
they're more likely to open up
now another one of my students at
georgetown several years ago was in a
job negotiation
and i said ask them a series of
questions
where the answer is no every time
oh that's so hard
and it's
to your benefit every time they say no
and that might be do you want to recruit
an unqualified person for this position
[Music]
you want to recruit somebody who's going
to fail
do you want me to fail
do you want me to be so anxious
about my salary
that i can't perform well
are you against me building my career
so he spent some time
thinking about all the things that he
would like to get him to say yes to
switched it to a no oriented question
what's a yes question do you want me to
be successful
the no question is
do you want me to fail
um i've never had a we've we've
counseled people to ask bosses that
across
the planet yeah
and nobody's ever pushed back
of course so this guy came up with 12 no
oriented questions
they came back with a salary that was so
much higher than their original offer
wow that the interview committee had to
actually go back to the cfo
to get
approval for the salary
i need to do that
that's that is so interesting that's i'm
gonna i've i've been incorporating a lot
of these things but i think uh that's
something that i don't um put enough uh
emphasis on actually the no orientated
question so i'm gonna put more emphasis
on that it's huge i mean it's
the only downside to it is
it will make such a difference in your
effectiveness
that you'll forget to learn the other
stuff yeah there you go it's like it's
like when you're starting to learn to
drive well in the uk anyway um because
we drive manual everything it's
difficult you have to do a bunch of
different things all at once um and then
it all becomes automatic obviously um i
saw um as well you talk about um
negotiation tips for women um which is
interesting i want to get to that but
before i do um
do you think that um men and women um
are different
um when it comes to negotiating
um like is one sex better than the other
um give me your honest opinion i'm i
don't take any offense on this show it's
yeah it's very non-pc we're good well
i'm gonna i'm gonna answer yes and no
okay yeah i know i sound like a
politician
women pick
the black sworn method up faster than
men do
i mean it's it's empathy based
not sympathy but empathy and it's
listening based
yeah now at the top performer end
gender makes no difference
like if you study it if you're if you're
coachable if you're willing to learn
then gender completely falls away what
we've seen
and i think it's more of a nurture
than nature thing because when you start
talking about gender differences or any
differences
it's really is it nature versus nurture
i mean we're all kind of born the same
blank slate
now typically across the globe
boys are
nurtured to fight sooner
females are nurtured to communicate
sooner they even though males and
females
up to adolescence
are pretty much exactly the same size
physical capabilities
you know 10 year olds you get them all a
bunch of 10 year olds together for a
sport
the girls are going to be every bit as
physically capable as the boys
the girls are going to undergo a growth
spurt two or three years before the boys
do 12 13 14 they're all going to be a
head taller than boys
the boys are going to catch up and pass
him physically
knowing this is coming
women globally know that ultimately
the females in their society are going
to be physically weaker than the men
so they need to know the soft skills
sooner they start getting coached on it
from the very beginning
so the coaching for soft skills and
listening and understanding is given to
women sooner
than it's given to men
generally speaking
you might not like that this is true
but if you want to look at the data it's
inarguable
that regardless of the society
that's true no matter how enlightened
the society is
that tends to be the case
so women get a head start on listening
and understanding
and they get more of a head start on
sympathy but if if you can make the
transition from sympathy to empathy you
pick it up faster so that's why i
believe
is the main reason
why women pick this up faster than men
but then at the top end there's no
difference in a gender either good at it
or not doesn't that make any difference
whether you're a man or a woman
the reason i ask is because
don't you think women tend to be um
again everything's a generalization but
um do you think women stereotypically
tend to be more agreeable and less
likely to take risk whereas men would be
more disagreeable more likely to take
risk and so when it comes to negotiating
um a man is more likely to say actually
no you know i that's that's not going to
work for me and is more likely to risk
losing the opportunity
um well
you know
likelihood and why are two separate
issues
and um in the middle of the bell curve
you know the
the d players to the
b minus players
um
the men are more encouraged
among their peers to take the risk right
you know what's your social feedback
what are your examples around you
basically still
the work workplace is majority male
so the men have more examples
of people being aggressive
the women don't have fewer examples
now most of these are examples of bad
negotiation but it still doesn't mean
that's not most of the examples that are
out there
i also think
that women are more aware of the
long-term negative impact of being
aggressive
and have developed a sense that
long-term it's a bad strategy
it looks good short-term
[Music]
but it really tends to be bad term
about in what way uh if the more
aggressive you are the more people
feelings and negativity you leave behind
you the more people want to hurt you in
return
it's a great way to accumulate enemies
burn bridges destroy relationships yes
it's a great way for long-term failure
yeah
and i think women sense this quicker and
they say all right so
i may not gain in the short term here
i may lose value short term
but long term
i'm seeing this aggressive guy
ultimately being hated by everybody
and i'm not sure i want to go there
something about that bothers me i don't
think my long-term success is there
and men are more celebrated for being
aggressive
and it's not pointed out to them how
badly it's damaging them long term
and then at some point of time they
either wake up or
they fail and they have to go someplace
else
that's so fascinating um i
personally um
have men to negotiate for me
um because i don't like to be
aggressive like i can be if necessary
but i i physically don't like the um the
energy that it puts me in does that make
sense it makes all the sense in the
world that it's why we train people to
be assertive and not aggressive um but i
think
even being assertive requires a certain
level of
whether it's like masculine energy or
something like that i'm not sure
um
i think it can be learned behavior
and it's where you're coming from with
your assertion
like for example you
you sound to me like somebody's not
trying to take away from the other side
that wants to make a good deal with
people
yes
so if you don't
lay out for them clearly
what you need
which is assertion
then you're making them guess
which is bad long term
like to be assertive
gently
politely respectfully
even deferentially
you're actually doing the other side a
favor
because otherwise
you're making them guess
as to what you really want
which means
you know the the correlation of success
there is diminishing with guesswork
as opposed to saying using a little
empathy
if you're assertive how you're worried
about coming across you're worried that
maybe you're being self-centered and
greedy
we like to teach people what would
before you say this what do you want to
deny
to make a two millimeter shift from
going from what do you want to deny to
just calling it out
you're afraid they're going to think
that you're self-centered and greedy
the wrong way would be to say i don't
want to seem self-centered and greedy
that's a denial
the right way would be
i'm probably going to seem self-centered
agree
here's what i need to make a great deal
with you
one of our rules in a black swan
when we make deals with people
we never want there to be any doubt
in the other side's mind
what it would take to make a great deal
with us
right if they choose to walk away
they're going to walk away fully
informed
and we don't say i have to have this
we say look
it's okay if you can't do this
you completely understand why you would
walk away while you would have other
priorities
but to make a great deal with us
here's what we gotta have
or we go our separate ways
no hard feelings
i've always coached my people
in my business development team
don't ever let anybody walk away from us
or don't ever walk away from anybody
unless you're sure
they know what we need
and then if we part company
everybody's fully informed and everybody
made a good decision
speaking of walking away what do you do
um when you feel like you may not have
any leverage so
um you know say you're um
i don't know you're working for yourself
and you don't have many clients one
month or whatever it is um
and you know you kind of need the
business um but
you can't get the money that you want so
you don't have that leverage it's not
like oh well if you won't pay me that's
fine i have a bunch of other clients
yeah well first of all um you can become
a hostage to the short term
that's a really easy thing to do because
once you're there you'll never get out
of it ever
i got to pay the bills i got to pay the
bills i got to make rent this month i
got you know i'm barely making rent this
month
i mean you never get out of the
short-term mindset
so
you've got to really work on the
six-month mindset or the long-term
mindset
now leveraging a deal you got a business
you really need the deal
what the other person really needs
is somebody that can rely on over a long
time
if you're delivering what you say you're
gonna deliver
replacing you is going to be very
expensive
[Music]
now you may need to point this out to
them because many people are in a in a
best price mindset i mean
how do you deal with someone who's
looking for to drive the price down
overall
ask a hard question
how do we make this deal and put me in a
position
where i'm your long-term vendor
that always delivers what you need
and i don't go out of business
and you don't have to replace me
every three months
because this gets us back to
[Music]
the prospect of loss
i talked about before danny kahneman's
nobel
prize win over behavior economics lost
things twice as much as an equivalent
gain
replacing you every two months is
expensive
and difficult
and if you can deliver the product
then the chances that they'll replace
you with someone who can't deliver are
very high
it's like having a good tenant in your
apartment
the next tenant
might not keep the place clean
the next tenant might be loud
then next tenant might always pay the
rent on time
but they trash the place so badly
that you're gonna have to put thousands
upon thousands of dollars into when you
kick them out yeah i mean vendor
client customer relationships are very
much the same if if you're delivering
it's far more expensive to replace you
with someone who doesn't deliver than it
is to pay you more that's the logic of
it
that's for lack of a better term to
leverage and i don't like the word
leverage i like influence okay you got
to shift them into long-term thinking
how do we do this so you don't got to
replace me every two months
that puts a loss in their head without
you making a threat
you want them to think about what's the
problem with replacing you
it's cheaper to pay you
so that you can make a living
than it is to replace you
because there's also down time between
replacing you
so
use a empathy and a how question
to get them to shift their thinking
so my final question for you is um how
do people prepare themselves when going
into a negotiation
um
the best thing is to be curious about
what might happen
uh curiosity is a superpower
okay there's a guy that wrote a book
called anti-fragile which means that you
thrive
from uh negative events
you know you don't just survive
you don't get knocked off your feet
you know
problems negative events trauma
you actually grow from it
curiosity is one of those terms you're
31 smarter in a positive frame of mind
curiosity is highly positive
preparing for the negotiations are most
people want to think what they want to
get out of the negotiation
what they're afraid might happen
those are two possibilities
think of five
right so maybe they'll give me some of
what i want what are they likely to give
me
as soon as you start thinking of more
than two possible outcomes
now you're curious and you're open
to the possibilities that will present
themselves
in the negotiation
and there are always better
possibilities your challenge is how do i
find them
if you're curious you're also easy to
talk to
when you're curious you're positive
you're pleasant
you're interested
the other side is more likely to reveal
stuff to you to help you make a better
deal
so when we we've got a block of
instruction we call caviar
which is an acronym and the c in caviar
is curiosity
there's a number of other things in
there to help you get your mind right in
front of a negotiation but if you can
just be curious
you'll be in good shape
so if you take anything away from this
conversation guys it should be curiosity
curiosity it's a superpower um chris i
want to thank you so much for coming on
it's been such a pleasure speaking with
you
thank you can i give some clues out if
anybody's curious yes i was about
to say yeah yeah guys will obviously
want to come follow you so where can
people follow you um tell us about your
book all right so uh the book has never
split the difference
yep
it's still
the top selling business negotiation
book on earth in all cultures
it sells well in china it sells well in
pakistan it sells well in india it's
cross-cultural success because we all
belong to the same culture of human
beings
so never split the difference a lot of
people get a long way
or never split the difference and then
just subscribe into our newsletter
because the newsletter's free and it's
concise and it's actionable
how do you subscribe
the website is black
swan
ltd.com b-l-a-c-k-s-w-a-n-l-t-d
dot com
upper right hand corner newsletter is a
tab for it's also known as the blog
click on that
subscribe
it's free
but really it's concise and it's
actionable
we'll ask you for your email uh
and we'll send you an email on tuesday
morning wherever you are in the world
it's calculated to give it to you early
tuesday morning
give you good food for thought so you
can negotiate well
that week do those two things
you're going to get better
chris if you send me um some links i can
put them in the description um after the
show so i can put everything in the
description below the links to
everything um the black swan group and
everything i can put them all in the
description below um you also have a
youtube channel um you also have a
youtube channel black swan group so guys
please go follow chris on youtube i'll
also put that um in the links uh in the
description below and are you active on
twitter i saw you on twitter but i'm not
sure if you're active
i'm a lot more on instagram than i am on
twitter you know that twitter stuff
stuff comes out when it's linked to
something i put up on instagram yeah all
right well guys all the information will
be in the description below um and the
book never split the difference um so i
want to thank you so much for coming on
it's been really um valuable especially
you know like i mentioned the beginning
of the show inflation is high
unemployment is high and uh you know
pretty tough times so people need to
know how to negotiate a better situation
for themselves
that's right
absolutely and thanks so much for coming
on thank you everyone for watching and
uh we will see you all next week bye bye
the leia hile pancho